greets her brother with joy as he
arrives from bucharest they're studying
medicine in western ukraine after the
city was bombed by russian forces they
fled to the border with romania they say
they waited there for nearly 15 hours
so there was no place to stand
like we were rushing somehow i don't
even remember how i crossed the border
twenty thousand indians study in ukraine
they're its largest group of foreign
students
many have made it home but one was
killed in a missile attack
the death was acknowledged in a meeting
headed by prime minister narendra modi
the meeting began
with an expression of
deep regret and condolences on the
tragic death death of
srinavin shekharappa gyanakodar
indian student who was studying in the
kharkiv national medical university
[Music]
thousands who managed to flee are
waiting in makeshift shelters in
neighboring countries
many waited for days in freezing cold
without food and say they were
discriminated against and assaulted by
ukrainian officials
the government has sent senior ministers
to border nations to help
the government is considering sending
military transport aircraft to speed up
evacuations diplomatically india is in a
difficult position it's called on both
sides to de-escalate the fighting and
has avoided calling russia an aggressor
at the united nations india has
abstained from resolutions condemning
russia it's an old ally and india's
biggest supply of military weapons it's
also a strategic partner in countering
china's expanding regional influence for
example on the sino-indian border
so far the russians have not
been against us on that on that issue
but now the chinese might pause that
position the chinese might force them to
take certain position on the india
pakistan issues so russian dependency on
china could have negative consequences
for us
india sending humanitarian aid to
ukraine as it seeks help from russia to
evacuate its nationals stranded in
eastern ukraine pav nimital al jazeera
new delhi